sorgt corona dafür dass die medikamente
in deutschland knapp werden tatsächlich
gibt es gerade engpässe doch dafür gibt
es verschiedene ursachen die mittel-
oder unmittelbar mit corona tatsächlich
zusammenhängen klicks um science fiction
die gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's wir kommen nicht nur
klopapier sondern auch mehl und hefe
sind in diesen tagen ganz besonders
gefragt immer öfter stehen kundinnen und
kunden aber auch in der apotheke und
müssen erfahren dass ihre gewünschten
medikamente vergriffen sind in manchen
fällen kann dann sogar nicht mehr mit
alternativen präparaten ausgeholfen
werden mitte märz hatte das
bundesgesundheitsministerium mitgeteilt
dass es einen versorgungsmangel für die
zugelassenen pneumokokken impfstoffe
gibt also eine impfung gegen
lungenentzündung die man unbedingt
machen sollte wenn man zur risikogruppe
für corona zählt dazu schreibt die
kassenärztliche vereinigung auf ihrer
webseite
das bundesgesundheitsministerium hat im
zusammenhang mit der korona virus
pandemie die impfung gegen pneumokokken
empfohlen seitdem ist die nachfrage
stark gestiegen praxen und apotheken
melden lieferschwierigkeiten für den 23
valente polysaccharid im stoff neu mowag
eine kurzfristige produktionssteigerung
ist bei impfstoffen nicht möglich und
auch das medikament chloroquin ein
kandidat für die therapie gegen 19 ist
knapp zurzeit gibt es nur eine
produktionslinie in pakistan
und da stehen die usa schon auf platz
eins in der warteschlange hier in
deutschland wurde es vom markt genommen
und kann nicht mehr gegen rezept in
apotheken bezogen werden das habe ich in
einem stichproben test hier in berlin
herausgefunden
es wurde für die krankenhäuser
eingesammelt allerdings will bayer die
produktion wieder in deutschland starten
fest steht europa und somit auch
deutschland ist darauf angewiesen aus
asien mit medikamenten beliefert zu
werden denn viele hersteller haben ihre
produktionen in den vergangenen jahren
nach indien und china verlegt und das
ganze kann natürlich in der aktuellen
situation zum problem werden die
lieferungen aus china haben in den
ersten monaten des jahres abgenommen und
indien verhängte ein exportverbot um die
eigene bevölkerung gut versorgen zu
können und auch die stabilität der
europäischen lieferketten ist in
krisenzeiten wie dieser gefährdet doch
derzeit sieht es wohl gut aus denn china
hat es wohl geschafft schnell für
nachschub sorgen
die produktion läuft langsam wieder an
laut dem bundesinstitut für arzneimittel
und medizinprodukte jedenfalls gibt es
derzeit keine lieferschwierigkeiten
wegen profit 19 dazu die
verbandssprecherin leonie heitmüller die
arzneimittelhersteller in deutschland
bemerkte noch keine folgen über das in
indien verhängte exportverbot fest steht
aber auch dass es bereits seit einigen
jahren immer wieder zu engpässen in der
medikamentenversorgung kommt dazu gibt
es online auch eine liste des
bundesinstituts für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte
demnach gab es beispielsweise im
vergangenen monat märz 2020
lieferprobleme beim medikament das bei
erwachsenen krebspatienten eingesetzt
wird um tumorschmerzen zu behandeln doch
auch das sei nicht auf die ausbreitung
des corona virus zurückzuführen wie die
bundesbehörde mitteilte allerdings
handelt es sich um eine zitat dynamische
lage die jeden tag neu bewertet werden
will so der behördensprecher
maik pommer im tagesspiegel dafür dass
derzeit einige medikamente vergriffen
sind liegt möglicherweise aber auch an
den hamsterkäufen einige kaufen also
nicht nur mehl hefe und klopapier
sondern auch arzneimittel omas umso
vorräte für mehr als drei monate zu
haben doch diese sorten hat fatale
folgen und die menschen die die medizin
zeitnah brauchen gehen im schlimmsten
fall leer aus doch das sind nur
spekulationen nennen den apotheken
selbst wird nicht mitgeteilt wie und
warum lieferengpässe zu stande kommen
dazu axel trish man vom berliner
apotheken vereinen die hersteller teilen
uns und den ärzten nicht mit warum
bestimmte mittel knapp sind und wann sie
wieder verfügbar sein werden eine gute
nachricht dabei falls mal ein medikament
vergriffen sein sollte kann man ja
meistens noch auf einen anderen
hersteller und ein alternatives
arzneimittel zurückgreifen falls sich
auch das als schwierig gestaltet sind
die ärztinnen ärzte gefragt die dann
andere wirkstoffe verschreiben können
natürlich ist es aber dennoch sinnvoll
sich rechtzeitig um nachschub zu kümmern
wenn man dringend auf ein medikament
angewiesen ist corona virus plasma
transfusion als heilmittel das scheint
ja im moment wirklich eine möglichkeit
zur seinen coup mit 19 zu heilen einfach
medizin bericht darüber also was kann
blut maßmann gegen coop 19 ausrichten
anklicken anschauen und unbedingt ein
fach medizin abonnieren sehr cool ein
neuer kanal bei unserem wissenschafts
netzwerkes 1054 bis dann
bleibt dran